flexy goons are a staple of recreational
mathematics but it's always the
hexaflexagon that you see one based on
the hex again it's got six edges and so
i'd you know someone called vy hearts
has made a whole series of videos about
these things i'm gonna go for the
Forgotten flexagon the tetra flexagon
one with four edges and to make it we're
gonna use a square of paper so the first
step is to fold it in half whichever way
you want they're both the same and one
of the reasons why I love the tetra flex
again is you don't need any glue if
you're making any of the hexaflexagons
you have to get some glue and stick bits
together whereas this one is just
folding and cutting so the first half
and half just split it into four
sections long ways I'm now gonna fold it
this way and if I make the creases
really like good creases because they're
gonna kind of be used as hinges later I
should end up with there we go it's a
piece of paper now split into 16 smaller
squares I'm gonna remove the center four
squares I'm gonna keep this ring of 12
squares intact I'm going to take these
middle ones out you could do that by
stabbing the citizen and just cutting
around but as we learnt from Katie
Eccles in her fold and cut their own
video you can do anything you want in a
single cut if you're a bit clever about
how you fold it so one cut down there
come on and we get that's not bad okay
there's the Center for squares gone we
can get rid of those and now we've got
the twelve on the outside so this is now
going to be three easy steps and one
difficult step so we start on the left
and we go around clockwise first step is
easy take the four on the outside fold
them up and over everything should line
up second step as we come around take
the three at the top fold them up and
over and they come down like that next
step as we keep coming around SiC these
three for them up and over and that is
the end of the easy steps
the only difficult step is when you take
up the bottom once you want to lift
these up as if we did it before that
first vault because what this to be
symmetric there's no beginning around so
what you've got to do is move the
original fold out of the way
without ruining it then lift this one up
and make sure the bit next to it goes
underneath so we kind of take all of
this bit next to it and just feed it
through until it's underneath and the
rest should follow and just kind of snap
into place and there you are
there is your four edged flexagon the
tetra flexagon so what's amazing about
the tetra flex again is it's got a lot
of faces so we've got face one on the
front here which I'm going to number
with ones and then if we fold it over
okay so ones on the front we've got twos
on the back so face one and face - so
you got twos on that face okay you got
ones on that face and then on the other
side of the ones we've got
what's blank so we'll label that with
three so that's face three so this is a
shape with at least three faces we got
face three there we got face one there
and I got face two there and what
happens is every time you fold it closed
one way so I'm forwarding the ones
closed with the twos on the outside I
can open it up on the opposite side so
it closes this way but then I open it
the other way around and I get a new
face and so I'm gonna label that one
where have I gone so far I've got one
there I got two there let's label this
one four and then let's see if we fold
this this way no that way they go this
way there's another one that's five
you're looking for six faces because if
we think of the original shape we made
there's my ring at twelve so there's 12
on the front there's 12 on the back so
I've got 24 of these little squares I'm
using up four for each one so if I
divide that by 4 I get 6 so there are
enough squares to make 6 whether or not
it does it's a slightly different
question 4 is there oh there it is this
6 okay
all right I'm gonna label this one here
6
and if we actually want to check that
we've got all of them face to hold it in
face one fold it in Phase three okay
we could pull the whole thing apart so
if we pump it back out again disassemble
it there we go
okay so there's all the faith we've
numbered every single square at some
point to make all of them there are two
different ways to put this back together
and if you do it the wrong way you will
get the mirror image kind of what we
started with them the numbers won't line
up again but if I carefully put it back
together
the same way we folded it originally
we're back to where we started there we
go and once you make one of these it's
kind of fun you play with it for a while
if you've not made one before it takes a
bit to work out where all the faces are
obviously you don't have to I've just
put numbers I'm not very creative if you
were one of these doodling
mathematicians you would draw pictures
or you know be artistic I've just
numbered it which is a bit sad I'm sorry
it is numberphile it's not doodle file
is it so I've numbered it so you could
be as creative as you want and you can
spend a lot trying to find them but if
you are into numbers after Y you're like
hang on
I know there are six faces but what
combinations of faces can I get at the
same time obviously I can get one
opposite two because when I started with
I can get three opposite one can I get
three opposite four can I get five
opposites like what combinations of
faces can you see at the same time and
that was the first thing I started
wondering when I taped one of these and
for a while I thought I you can get
combinations of faces but there's always
a one in there too
you never loses original two faces but
not know here's a five opposite of four
so you can you can get reasonably lost
right the original two faces are long
gone we have two new faces on the
outside and I when I heard it I was like
I want to work out the logic behind this
what is it which means I can get
different pairs and which ones are
possible and how do I go between them
and so I drew a diagram
okay diagram we're gonna use colors
because that's how we roll here this is
as close to artistic as we get so what
face is definitely possible so I first
did this actually I didn't do colors
what I did I was kind of lazy I was like
okay I'm gonna label that as being one
two so it's not a fraction 1/2 it's a
one opposite of two I was using my own
notation and then I went okay I can go
from that to one three so I put 1/3 on
my diagram and then I realize it's like
wait a minute one face always stays
there so whenever you flex
whichever one goes on the outside is
still there when you open it up you're
gonna change one at a time so when you
go from 1/3 to 1/2 the 1 doesn't change
that's like well I can kind of imagine
those ones being linked and so I can go
from 1/3 to 1/2 if I keep the 3 I can
get to 3 6 so over here somewhere I've
got 6 and 3 and I've kind of link those
up like that right and I started drawing
the network to try and work it out I'm
gonna show you the network I ended up
with because I'm particularly pleased
with it first of all I'm gonna put this
back to the starting state one's gonna
be read this there's one and one can be
opposite
let's do light blue it can be light too
I can only wear this too right so one is
opposite to okay so let's see what else
can I get opposite one well I can go
from one that can be opposite three okay
so I can have one three so I'm gonna put
one three down here that can be purple
or one can be opposite it's actually
it's horizontal and vertical so if I
fold it vertical fold you get three if I
fold a horizontal fold you get the other
ones that's five in there so five you're
gonna be an orange color and we'll put
five yeah
and so what I've done is I have run all
the ones in a line down here so this is
all the ones you get which have a one in
them and so I've still kind of got the
money the size use going on there okay
will do - next so - if we fold it
horizontally it's opposite six so it's
opposite six that way so that's going to
be six with two and then if I hadn't
folded that horizontal my folder
vertically - is opposite four so four is
gonna be dark blue and so that's gonna
be down here so now I have lined up all
the faces with two and actually we've
got another line going this way so there
are five combinations we found first and
how you can go between them but there
are other ones so if I go forward -
let's go back over here there's one two
in the middle again let's go out to one
of these let's go out to one opposite
five soar over here if I keep five there
I can get five opposite for okay falls
over here so what I can actually do is
extend the five line down here and then
I can extend the full line up here and
now I've got five four and that predicts
I can pop down here - four - because I'm
like preemptively locked that in but if
I keep four on the outside close it
sure enough there it is 4 - so that's
dropped me down there and I predict on
the opposite side over here if we extend
six down there and we extend three up
there that predicts we can have a 6 3
over there
sure enough let's get over that side as
where should we go so we're at four -
let's go back to 2 1 go back at 2 1 done
that let's go let's go down we go to 1 3
which ways that you know there is one of
three and then we should better pop up
there to be three opposite 6 sure enough
there it is there's 3 and 6 right and
then that's it these are the ones they
don't fill in but I was able to create
it's kind of a graph but I've put some
structure into it I've had straight
lines so I got 6 different colored lines
and whenever two of those lines crossed
that combination of faces as possible so
originally I just kind of sketch them
all over the place
and then I realized there was some logic
underneath them and I was able to then
arrange it to show the structure behind
what combinations of faces are possible
and that pleased me immensely so I've
been throwing some names of lexicons
around the way it works is you've always
got the number of faces followed by the
number of edges followed by flexagon so
this has got four edges so this is a
tetra flexagon and because we've got six
faces it's a hexa tetra flexagon six
faces four edges flexagon so the ones
you see online all the time are hexa
flexagon because they're made from
hexagons they've got six edges and then
have many faces the easy one the one you
see all the time is the Tri
hexaflexagons and you've got three faces
this one gives you six out of the box
with a lot of work you can make a hexa
hexaflexagon so six edges six faces my
goodness it's a real pain so the Tri
hexa takes a bit of work making a chain
of nine equilateral triangles
technically ten because you want to glue
once you've got those ten you've got to
fold them and glue them and you get
three faces if you make a chain of 19
you've got four triangles
you've got to fold it you've got to fold
it again you've got to glue it right
you've got to realise you did that wrong
pull it apart in my experience and a lot
of effort later you get six faces where
is this no glue no messing around cut
out a square cut out a smaller square
bit of folding six faces are all yours
and the middle bit guess what you can do
with this I think we all know what we're
gonna do with this you're gonna make
self a smaller tetra flexagon and the
bit your curl of that you're gonna make
a smaller one again right you're gonna
make fractal you're gonna make gradually
smaller and smaller and infinite
sceneries diminishing they do approach a
limit of total amount of paper hexxit it
reflects against like this that
forgotten flexagon is best flexagon I've
sat at a conference or be at a
recreational math conference at the the
conference dinner and the person next to
me is gone do you wanna see some new
flexagon x' I've gone yes